a few episodes ago on the live from The
Beacon Theater Tracy Morgan show we
discussed something that we need to
follow up on okay
and that is yes oh my the Joop scent for
Men
Let me let me bring people up to speed
please Tracy's on the show at the Beacon
Theater Tracy Morgan the great Tracy
Morgan and just before the show they say
Tracy's here so I go down to say hi to
him
and he gives me a big hug and I am
suddenly transported to a better world
because he has this Aroma
um he wears and I asked him about it he
wears a cologne but of course being
Tracy I just said what are you wearing
and I I didn't know what he was talking
about either I think I pulled the crowd
I don't think a lot of people knew what
dupe was none of us on stage did yeah we
didn't know on stage I don't know about
colognes where there's an exclamation
point in the name it's it is a red flag
to me yeah and also the color of the
poem is literally a red flag because
that's the that's the color of your
urine when you're dying of kidney
failure
it is uh that is a cranberry blood yeah
you just pour that in a toilet after
someone's used it and you will freak
them out also it just says Joop
exclamation mark home and there's
literally not another word on the bottle
like anything nothing
um well I was saying to Tracy I think
you know do you think this would up my
game with this and he was I have to say
Tracy's a very convincing person he's a
very powerful personality and he doesn't
half recommend anything
Joop he really really thought my life
would be enhanced if I had some Jupe on
me do you remember what else you said
you said that you would put some on go
home not say anything and see what Liza
said yes I will do that yeah so we can
report back okay this is interesting
um my wife has been in New York City
talking to lawyers for some reason but
that's not the important thing no no
she's been in New York and she gets back
today
so this is perfect
because when I go home I'm not going to
say anything I'm just going to see what
happens I'm going to introduce her to
the new Conan yeah all right so try
something yeah try this so oh it's got a
little sprayer and what do you do do you
spray it right on I want to smell it I
think technically you're supposed to
spray it and then walk into it I just
smell it first that's so close
okay
I just fired it myself
[Music]
I am not kidding I just held my wrist
out held the bottle up and then saw this
[ __ ] spray into my eyes
I I'm not I wasn't trying to do it
clearly yeah I was alone of course not
I've never worn a cologne oh that was oh
I don't know how I
feel about it what do you think
oh that I don't need it what does it
smell like
um what are the notes well I'm getting a
could de-vegetate rainforest I don't
want to be mean but it does smell like
this CL this Motel I used to stay in
with my family in Lake Tahoe or I'm not
even if Tracy was here he'd probably say
I love that Motel I was there all the
time I used to check in I used to roll
around on the sheets I jump it up and
roll around on the sheets
um it is uh well it's it's sweet that's
for sure it's got a sweetness to it whoa
I'm not I'm trying to think of what
notes What notes very strong here here
you try some on your wrist don't worry
I'm getting like
uh I'm getting
1930s Grandma yeah yeah Grandma right
yeah masculine yeah pass it around take
a swig on the bottle it says and now
with more Grandma
they just grind them up
what I just it's I have to say Tracy
smelled really good he did and also was
wearing he said he wore a half a bottle
yeah he puts a lot of it on and I do
think that's what he was wearing he
doesn't lie about Jupe it reminds me of
you know Old Spice was a really cheap
thing but I have a fondness for that
because my grandpa and Dad wore it and I
probably wouldn't balk if I had to wear
that but it's really cheap you know yeah
I never put on a cologne but uh I might
start wearing jube now what do you think
do you think people would accept me if I
started wearing jute I think you're not
a clone guy hey do you think Tracy would
do an ad with me for Jupiter like it's
on the subway oh my God would that be
great and me and uh and Tracy and we're
and it's for Jupe I want to see you
pouring it on yourself I think you guys
let me see that bottle you guys should
do come up with your own fragrance and
you read it through the back and it's
just Conan and Tracy Morgan for pooch
you see it backwards yeah I think there
are some people who are clone people and
you're not a cologne person no I'm not a
cologne person do you go to the club a
lot
do you go are you asking me I'm asking
him do you hit the clubs I've never hit
the clubs
at the club never never hit the clubs
but you used to hit the club all the
time lots of cologne really yeah would
you and what is that for is it to cover
I wore a perfume yeah but why are people
why do you think are there women that
like a man to wear a scent yeah I think
so I used to like nice scents on guys
you know but it's
I don't need it anymore but you know
that was a different time that was a
different sonar
you were a married mother of uh twin
boys yeah yeah so you shouldn't be uh
hungering for another man's scent no no
and also now I'm worried about wearing
scents because what if the boys react
weirdly to it so I don't know
um I didn't yeah I don't need it okay
well I I'm all down with uh
you know it's not like I have a product
right now that I'm you know really
Tethered to never really had one but why
not dupe let me ask you this when you go
home tonight Liza will have been out of
town she's gonna come home and you're
gonna have this really sweet perfume on
you and she's gonna think well no she
won't she was not gonna know
she is not going to think that
she's gonna think oh he's doing a bit
for the podcast yeah exactly I wish this
car what's his podcast bit
um Liza sleeps very soundly at night
knowing that uh yeah that I I'm not out
there it might even just be in for a
little like yeah it's it's so funny I
did say to her once not long ago I said
if you did find out that I was uh
cheating on you isn't there some part of
you that would be impressed with my time
because
you know that's what I never have
understood I have no desire to be that
person I am very uh happy with my choice
but
I'm always once people do that and I
always think wait a minute how do you
keep all that [ __ ] straight and the
energy and time yeah I gotta go see you
know Matt Gourley and and Adam sacks to
talk about the and then we're in a
restaurant you know with FiFi and uh and
she's like she missed your own broy and
you really think you're gonna get me my
own pork
TV
I guess has that how's that chicken
Milanese Mr and Brian you're such a
sophisticated
wait a minute that's the phone uh oh
hello Liza I'm here with uh uh uh
Eduardo wait did I say oh no no Matt and
Corley I mean Matt and Adam died that's
why I couldn't meet with them and then
Wizards I mean I would pick it up yeah
then I have to kill you yeah gee Mr
O'Brien why are we killing people
I like that that's my that Conan would
wear it that's my mistress she's Chomp
and gum yeah she's got big high heels
off the bus from Kansas to get a podcast
to get a podcast
she Mr O'Brien
yeah the bee's knees well we'll report
back on what Eliza says about your new
sense well before this airs people may
read about it
yeah what yeah uh Conan O'Brien shot by
wife
cheating but for wearing that no just
for wearing the scent not cheating at
all
um but uh yeah Joop
look for it where do you look for it
Amazon 35 a bottle is that true I I
thought it was like a like a Rite Aid
set I bet it is I think it's one of
those you know uh like Pharmacy colognes
you know what I like it I like the way
my wrist smells right now and I like the
way I'm gonna smell when I go home
tonight and we will report back on how
Conan wearing Joop and not saying a word
to his wife goes over I'd give it one
more spray just to make sure no no no I
am gonna you're gonna dab it I might
take this with me okay yeah and and hit
myself hard before I walk in the door
yeah I want it to be noticeable yeah
okay just stop it and then I'll be you
have to do CPR in our cats okay
sure this is deadly 35 dollars so
for 35 didn't you put it on the show
card I don't have a show card fantastic
just as I ordered it
decide to create it